نحن الان عند مفترق ضبيط في شارع الجلاء
هذه المنطقه التي كانت تتواجد فيها قوات
الاحلال لمده ست ايام ست ايام كنا محاصرين
داخل المنازل لم نستطع الخروج وثقنا
العديد من الشهادات من خلال النوافذ
الضيقه في المنزل الذي كنا نتواجد فيه
وثقنا شهاده عائز الجنود رايناهم باعيننا
وهم يتمشون في الشوارع ايضا الياته
ودباباته كانت تتواجد في هذه المنطقه بشكل
كثيف وبشكل كبير يقومون باطلاق نار بشكل
كبير وثقنا العديد من الشهادات المهمه
التي يجب ان تصل الى العالم عن حجم جرائم
قوات الاحتلال التي ارتكبتها في هذه
المنطقه قاموا بتجريب كل شيء كما نرى ايضا
خلفي يتواجد جمعيه الشبان المسيحيه التي
سقط فيها اكثر من 12 شهيدا حتى الان جسس
ما زالت موجوده داخل الجمعيه لم يستطع
الوصول الوصول لهم احدا ايضا المباني تم
احراقها من الداخل
تجريف المنازل اطلاق القذائف بشكل مستمر
كما نرى هذا هو شارع الجلاء هنا مفترق طيط
ايضا وهنا ايضا شارع الوحده العائلات التي
كانت محاصره مازالت تحاول الخروج من
المنطقه باتجاه غرب مدينه غزه ايضا شارع
شارع الجلاء باتجاه مفترق الصرايا كما نرى
حجم الدمار ايضا شارع الوحده باتجاه مجمع
الشفاء الطبي هذا المكان الذي تم قصفه هي
شهيد وهي شهيد وهي شهيد فيش جرافات فيش
كفشات الشهداء ه زي ما انت شايف بظلهم على
الحاله هذه اسبوع ع ايام ما حد بدور مش
انه ما حد بدور لانه في اليات في معدات فش
طر تسعف الناس وتك الناس وتدفن صاروا
الشهدا في غزه يروا الشوارع زي ما انت
شايف ما حد مدور اج الدبابات هنا واليهود
جرفه كسروا وخبطه ونزلوا الحيطه هذه الناس
هنا فوق ال 150 نفر يمكن 200 نفر عددهم
نسوان واطفال ورجال وما لقيناهم سابوهم
وراحوا بعد شويه اف 16 ضربتهم رجعوا ثاني
الدبابات دفنو هم احياء وهم مايتين دفنوا
عليهم كمان الصور نزلوه عليهم وردم عليهم
وهم يستغيثوا وحتى اسم هم ستسمع اطلاق نار
كمان عليهم وقعدوا يزعقوا عليه نفس وين
ننزلهم مش قاعدين ننزلهم احنا وعد ترين
على الدفاع المدني خلصت بطيه الجوال وبنا
على الدفاع المدني انه يجي غيس بس
الدبابات كانت موجوده والضرب والخبط وكان
ما فيش ولا طريق كان طخ عليهم هم زين طخ
زي المجانين لقيت مراه غادت هي وطفل صغير
رضيع راسهم رايح فيش رؤس لهم مقطع رؤسهم
جبناهم ودفنوه اهليهم دفنوهم هناك في
الارض الوادي اللي غادت وهاي اللي صار